okay real quick I've got a voicemail to
play for you today that number is two
one nine two david p anytime of day you
can call here is a voicemail about me
and talk show host stephanie miller take
a listen to this yeah you stephanie
miller y'all are kind of y'all are kind
of nerdy i mean y'all are y'all don't
have a anybody from a republican point
of view okay you know i already know how
you're on the air or stephanie miller i
think y'all are both idiots hmm thank
you okay no thank you but really really
appreciate it
alright on the bonus show today air B&B
has new anti-discrimination rules we
will talk about those a paralyzed
pregnant woman wearing a bionic suit has
completed a half marathon and we have
yet more bad news
i meanit's is there ever really good
news out of the diamond industry i say
no but we have even more bad news out of
the diamond industry on today's bonus
show sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership and get instant access to the
bonus show